c'est avec 50 minutes de retard que les
coureurs ont pris le départ au centre
ville de montréal
50 longues minutes où les coureurs de
béton toho demeurer actif et réchauffé
pour éviter les blessures
tantôt se reposer pour bien gérer des
énergies l'organisation explique un
manque d'effectifs a causé d'importantes
délai dans la gestion de la sécurité
tout au long du parcours
le grand patron d'événements se
confondait en excuses je n'aurais jamais
donné le départ tension qu'on aura pris
les effectifs puis je vous le dis et je
le redis j'en suis
j'en suis très touché parce que c'est
paula expérience que je décris j'en
reçois mon nouvel adn on est au
centre-ville de montréal à regarder tout
ce qu'on a dit ce matin j'ai failli à
tous les athlètes
j'ai failli à leurs familles mais les
gens qui font le marathon qui déjeunent
3 heures 2 heures avant l'événement le
retarder d'une heure ça veut dire qu'ils
vont ils sont une heure à dépenser des
calories pour rien ça que ça peut jouer
sur la fin de la course
non
un retard qui n'a pas du tout nuit aux
kenyans en visite à montréal
boniface kong in a remporté la course
dans la catégorie élite chez les hommes
après avoir parcouru la distance en 2
heures 15 minutes et 28 secondes
françois jarry a été le meilleur
canadien
il a terminé 5e chez des élites arrêtant
le chronomètre à 2h26 c'est difficile il
faisait chaud et simple auteur pascal
m'emmener il fallait qu'on passe
totalement 10 amis donc c'est un peu
chaotique par respect au fil entre les
gens afin dé musique est un peu fatigué
a lancé près de huit mille coureurs qui
ont pris le départ pour le 21 points 1
km le demi marathon et 2500 pour le
marathon total de 42 points 2
reste à voir si sûr car en retard ce
défaut de logistique est également un
parcours jugé un peu plus difficile
nuiront vos inscriptions pour l'an
prochain il si mickaël leroy
radio-canada à montréal